if i worked at ross dress for less it
would be that sort of thing
is that's right russ matthews
yeah if i was a math teacher
i know you see your brain
your noodle is cooking
you're catching us mid-conversation
[Music]
it's jeff goldblum and we are going to
hit you with rapid fire questions that's
what i like there's no point to any of
this you understand that's what i like
okay good i can't believe i'm getting to
meet you just for starters this is the
first time we've we've actually uh been
in fleshy proximity yeah
this is the first five minutes of our
actual meeting so nice to meet you so
far
am i everything you wanted me to be and
more i'm a great admirer of yours oh my
god you're a vision in blue wait a
minute let me drink you in yeah you
that's a navy that's a lovely midnight
blue or navy
thank you for thinking but it's azara
thank you very much nothing wrong with
that no you look fantastic and you're
right you're a wedding ring you're yeah
you're it's beautiful i designed this
you did i did i'm glad i asked about it
my eye fell on immediately i've got a
lovely thing beautiful may i yeah
my beloved uh emily had it had it
engraved inside so we're gonna do that
when we get on the wedding day we're
going to have the engravement
you know when's the big day i'm planning
now you are can i put this back on you
make it down on one meeting this
definitely this doesn't mean
no emily i say that with respect
how long have you been married i but you
know i just thought you should ask russ
i just had we just had our anniversary
happy anniversary very much like what's
the what's the
lesson to have a happy life with
somebody any advice how do i know you
you know as well as i do you've got
seven years together well ten we've been
together ten and we celebrate our
meeting anniversary too we met at uh
equinox gym on sunset
they were just pumping iron
well i was palm petty a little bit and
she is a as a gymnast she was in the
olympics
uh a rhythmic gymnast you know the
ribbon in the ball that's the best one
it's the best one she still does it and
does contortion too and valet and uh
ariel stuff she doubled emma stone in la
la land she did the aerial dancing
outside the planetarium that's her what
that's your wife that's my wife
and now we've had two children
children for us so we didn't answer to
the question you know you have to get
lucky i think i i i have no who knows
you know go day by day how long have you
guys been together i'm good we are going
on two years together we're fantastic
yeah and uh so we're planning the
wedding now but this is about you oh
okay so we literally haven't gotten to a
single question yet we're just bonding
but do you even want to get today
successfully it doesn't matter to me
anything we'll do one word answers i
like surprises of any kind do you eat
enough vegetables every day do i eat
enough vegetables every day
yes i do i would say no you can never
eat enough vegetables now that i'm
thinking about it i i retract my first
answer um
i try to
greens of some kind so
the answer is yes so the answer is is
yes
i'm proud of you and your fiber intake i
really am well fiber you know you must
stay
mobile
you
you must keep things on the move proud
of you
instagram or tick tock instagram uh you
know that's the only uh
place that i've ventured into on the
social media tick tock i did a little
tech talk hey i'm here to promote this
show with the world card jeff goldberg
of course and dance this is one of the
first five episodes dance dogs
monsters magic and fireworks and then
for the dance i went to the collab crib
in atlanta and they do these things i'm
sure you know better than i did they
introduced me to it these dances that
last for you know uh
yes but they made they do these great
dances i prefer i did one with them et
cetera et cetera so that's tick tock but
i myself still do not
indulge yeah i don't get the tick tock
no
i have to tell you i'm so proud of your
vegetable intake and that's my that's
all i have for you
i feel like we could be friends forever
i love you ross
[Music]